[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بالعناوين
اوكرانيا تستعد لهجوم الربيع المضاد
سيناريوهات محتمله وبمساعدات غربيه اما عن
فرصه النجاح فهي جيده للغايه
الرئيس الاماراتي يعين منصور بن زايد
نائبا للرئيس الى جانب محمد بن راشد وخالد
بن محمد بن زايد وليا للعهد في ابوظبي
هو بايدن يدخلان سجالا سريا وعلنيا قاعده
العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه تحت
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
[موسيقى]
شرف الشتاء على انقضاء لكن لا يبدو ان
الامر كذلك بالنسبه للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه حسب ما توقع الكراميل عرقل
الشتاء بعض المعارك لكن برحيله ياتي
الربيع ومساحه هنا تتسع لمعارك اكثر وربما
اطول في الصراع الوجودي الرئيسين الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين والاوكراني
انهما قادران على الفوز بحسب دبلوماسيين
غربيين ما يرونه العائق الاساسي في الحرب
[موسيقى]
نبدا اولا من اخر التطورات حيث وصفت
الخارجيه الروسيه قرار الولايات المتحده
بحجم بيانات نوويه بانه اخفاق خبيث والدار
الامتلاء الامتثال لمعاهده وقال نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسيسار جاري ان واشنطن لم
تعلق مشاركتها رسميا في معاهده ستارت
وبناء على ذلك ملزمه بالامتثال الكامل
لبنودها
قبل ذلك اعلنت روسيا عن بدء تدريبات
عسكريه على صواريخ يارس النوويه
الباليستيه العابره للقارات التدريبات
تجريبي مشاركه اكثر من 3000 عسكري وبوجود
300 قطعه من المعدات العسكريه
[موسيقى]
مع اقتراب معارك الاستنزاف شرق اوكرانيا
من ذروتها يتحول الانتباه مشاهدينا مره
اخرى الى هجوم الربيع المضاد الذي تخطط له
كياف احدى الجبهات المحتمله لهذا الهجوم
هي الجبهه الجنوبيه وتحديدا خرسون وايضا
زابوريا اي هجوم منهما سيعرض شبه جزيره
القرم للخطر ويعزلها عن باقي الاراضي
المتصله بها والخادعه بطبيعه الحال
للسيطره الروسيه هذه الجبهه ولكونها منطقه
مسطحه ستكون اكثر ملائمه للدبابات
والمدفعيه الاوكرانيه ومن المرجح ان يتم
تعزيز الجبهه بالدبابات الغربيه وعربات
المشاه القتاليه مراقبون يرون ان اي تقدم
اوكراني من زابوريجيا باتجاه ميلوتوكول
سيكون الانسب لاوكرانيا لانه سيقسم القوات
الروسيه الى قسمين جزء في شبه جزيره القرم
وايضا جزء اخر في الشريط الشرقي من
اوكرانيا كما نشاهد وفي هذه الحاله سيكون
لدى القوات الروسيه في القرم خط امداد
وحيد وهو عبر الجسر الرابط بين روسيا
وشبه الجزيره وقد تنقطع الخطوط اذا ما تم
استهداف هذا الجسر مجددا روسيا تراقب
الوضع عن كثب واشاره اشاره فعليا تقارير
اعلاميه روسيه الى انكياف حشدت حوالي 75
الف جندي على جبهه زابوريا تقرير اخر
لنيوزوي قال ان تركيز متزايد للمدفعيه
الاوكرانيه على جبهه دومباس الشرقيه مع
استعداد اوكرانيا للهجوم المضاد في حين
يسود اعتقاد بان اوكرانيا ستشون هجوما
مضادا في الربيع قال مستشار رئيس
الاوكراني ان بلاده ستشن الهجوم فقط عندما
تكون جاهزه لذلك وزير الدفاع الامريكي
تحدث عن هذه الهجمات المضاده واكد ان هناك
فرصه جيده للغايه لنجاحها مضيفا انه على
الارجح ستكون لاوكرانيا اليد العليا ضد
القوات الروسيه خلال الاشهر المقبله
في الاثناء دعا رئيس الوزراء البولنديه
الشركات الخاصه والحكوميه والاجنبيه الى
زياده انتاج الذخيره عبر انشاء مصانع
جديده متخصصه معربه عن رغبه بلاده بتخصيص
اكثر من 460 مليون دولار للاستثمار في
القطاع وذلك في الوقت الذي يسع حلفاء
اوكرانيا الى زياده الامدادات قبل تنفيذ
الهجمات المضاده في الربيع
في المقابل شدد مجلس الامن الروسي على ان
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا ستحقق هدفها
بنزع السلاح من كياف وضمان سلامه اراضي
روسيا وقال سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي
نيكولاي باتريشوف ان سلوك الغرب الذي وصفه
بالاستفزازي في اوكرانيا سيؤدي لعواقب
كارثيه
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من موسكو
سيرجي شاشكوف المحلل العسكري الروسي اهلا
بك سيد يعني من جديد عاد الحديث عنه هجوم
الربيع المضاد يعني ما توقعك للمسار الذي
سيكون عليه هذا الهجوم ومن اي جبهات والى
اي جبهات سينطلق
مساء الخير اهلا بالفعل هناك اخبار تثبت
نيه كيف لشدنا الهجوم المضد وهذا الهجوم
المضاد سوف يكون قويا والقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه تستعد
لهذه الاعمال
القتاليه بكل جديه هناك
تعزيزات قتاليه كثيره تاتي حاليا من بعد
دول الغرب بما فيها المعلومه هناك مدرعات
والمدفعيه
ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي وتم التشد اكثر من
عشرين لواء منها
الويه
مدرعه والمدفعيه والى اخره فعلى ما يبدو
الهجوم سوف يتم شنه في اونه قريبه
طبعا التفاصيل الخطه العسكريه الاوكرانيه
ولكن من الواضح ان هذا الهجوم المضاد سوف
يبدا في بدايه الشهر المقبل ابريل نيسان
الاتجاهات الاتجاهات
براي الخبراء العسكريين الاتجاه الرئيسي
سوف يكون الى جنوب باتجاه شبه جزيره القرم
وبنفس الوقت سوف
تحاول الى القوات الاوكرانيه بشان
الهجومات الثانويه ربما باتجاه منطقه دون
باس
لجذب القوات القتاليه الروسيه من
جبهه زوبولوجيا وجبه كرسون وحتى
التوغل الى الاراضي الروسيه في محافظات
حدوديه مثل
اخره بنفس
جذب
الدفاعات الروسيه
ومنع
البحث عن الاتجاه الرئيسي ما يخص
النجاح الذي اشار اليه وزير الدفاع
الامريكي وهو وصفه هو انه احتمال احتمال
النجاح عالي جدا انا لا اشارك هذه وجهه
النظر لان قد تكون هذه العمليات الهجوميه
الاوكرانيه
معركه اخيره من الواضح ان هذه المعركه سوف
تكون حاسمه وطاحنه
بالرغم من الاستعدادات
المكثفه التي تقوم بها الوحدات الاوكرانيه
الان نعم هناك اكثر من ثمانين الف مقاتل
وبيئات من الدبابات
والاف من الاليات والى اخره
وجمع الذخائر لكن
الجانب الروسي يراقب هذه الاستعدادات
ويتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه طبعا
على التطورات الميدانيه واعود اليك حيث
قال يفقيني مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر ان عمليات
قوته في متادت لهزيمه الجيش الاوكراني
ولكنها ايضا تسببت في اضرار كبيره لقواته
كما قال بيجوجين ان انتصار فاجنر في بخموت
سيقلب بشكل كبير العمليه الخاصه راسا على
عقب
في الاثناء وثق جنديون اوكراني حجم الدمار
في بخموت قائلا ان المدينه تتعرض لقصف
مستمر بالالغام
تتعرض المدينه لقصف مستمر بالالغام عمليا
لا يوجد احد في الشارع الجميع اما في
مواقع او في ملاج اود ان اقول ان هذا
الجزء من المدينه يخضع لسيطره القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه ولا يمكن للعدو الوصول
اليه
[موسيقى]
الى دومباز تحديدا في
فوليدار وبعد مرور نحو شهر من تعيينه
افادت مصادر لمجله الامريكيه بان
الكونونيل الجنرال الروسي روستم مراجعه من
منصبه كرئيس المنطقه العسكريه الشرقيه في
اوكرانيا وكان القائد العسكري الخمسيني
مسؤولا عن قياده الهجوم في مدينه
فاهيلدار في منطقه جمباز لكن مصادر نيوزبي
قالت انه استبعد بعدما فشلت روسيا في
الاستيلاء على المدينه بعد معركه استمر
ثلاثه اسابيع خسرت خلالها موسكو عشرات
المركبات المدرعه ورغم ان الكرملين لم
يؤكد نبا اقصائه الا ان مجموعه فاجنر
لطالما انتقدت مرادف لانه فشل فيلدار
من موسكو ينضم الينا من جديد السيد سرجي
شاشكووف المحلل العسكري الروسي يعني سيد
شاشكوف نشاهد بانه هناك اقصاء لقاده
عسكريين من جديد من الجانب الروسي
وبالمقابل هناك دعم عسكري غربي كبير جدا
مدرعات وصلت ان كان من المانيا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن الغرب
بشكل عام كيف يمكن لموسكو مواجهه كل هذا
الدعم الغربي العسكري
بدايه فيما يخص التغيرات في
المستوى القيادي للجيش والقوات المسلحه
المصادر الامريكيه تقول ان فريق اول ركن
مرادف تم
طرده من الجيش والى اخره هذا الخبر لا
اساس له اطلاقا فريق اول مرادف الان مجاز
وفي انتظار تعيينه لمنصب اخر ربما يكون
اعلى مثل ما صار لفريق اول
اخر كان قائدا لهذه الجبهه في سابق وايضا
كان هناك اخبار انه تم طرده واقالته
بينما تم تعيينه قائدا لرئاسه
اركان القوات البريه الروسيه يعني تم
ترفيعه في مصر هذا واحد فيما يخص معركه
ضخمه
اهميه معركه ضخموت من الناحيه السياسيه
تتفوق على اهميتها العسكريه لانه مدينه
كبيره
يعني هي عشت ضعف عقائد من ماري اوبل وليس
هناك
الان القوات العسكريه بمساعده قوات لم
تستطع ان تحسمها بعد كل هذه الشهور
والدمار الحاصل والخسائر التي تحدث عنها
الجانب الروسي يعني
هذا كله صحيح نسبيا لان مدينه ضخمه او
مدينه
تسمى هي في روسيا
تحولت الى رمز يعني الرئيس الرئيس
اصدر الامر بالتمسك بتلك
المدينه رغما عن الثمن في الارواح
والمعدات لذلك نعم بالفعل هناك معارك
قويه ودمويه وطاحنه تستغرق حتى الان ولكن
من الناحيه العسكريه هذه المدينه ليست لها
قيمه عسكريه استراتيجيه وحتى عمليه ايتيه
ولكن سياسيا
وباعتبارها الرمز للصمود من قبل النظام
الحاكم في في كيف
هذا هي المدينه التي لا يمكن
الاستهلا عليها نعم سوف يتم عليها خلال
خلال الفتره الزمنيه قصيره هذا لا شك فيه
اذا
[موسيقى]
من
فوليدار الى سوليدار هو حرف واحد يتغير
ومعه طبعا تتغير النتائج في الاولى روسيا
تعاني كما ذكرنا في الثانيه بسطت سيطرتها
لكن قبل هذه السيطره استفادت اوكرانيا عبر
ملح سوليدار الذي بات جزءا من تمويل
المجهود الحربي في كيافا القوات الروسيه
سيطرت على المدينه في يناير الماضي الا ان
الملح المستخرج من مناجمها يستخدم الان
لشراء طائرات مسيره نائب رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني للابتكارات والعلوم ميخائيل
فيدروف اعلن انه سيتم شراء اكثر من 2200
مسيره كميكازي لاستهداف القوات الروسيه
اشار المسؤول الاوكراني الى جمع ما يقرب
من مليون و600,000 دولار عبر منصه خاصه
انشات لجمع التبرعات داخل اوكرانيا هذه
المنصه مشاهدينا اعتمدت على بيع مئه الف
عبوه من الملح من مدينه سوليدار تم بيع
الواحده منها مقابل 13 دولارا و56 سنتا
نائب رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني اشار في وقت
سابق الى ان ثلاث شركات اوكرانيه جديده
مدعومه بتبرعات خاصه ستعمل على صنع طائرات
مسيره لاستخدامها في استهداف القوات
الروسيه المسيرات لعبت دورا مهما كما
تعلمون لكل من اوكرانيا وروسيا في هذه
الحرب
[موسيقى]
تحدثنا عن معارك على الارض ومعارك محتمله
لكن هناك معارك اخرى على عده جبهات
والاقتصاد اكبر اليوم خرج الرئيس الروسي
بوتين لوقره بان العقوبات على بلاده قد
يكون لها تاثير سلبي على المدى المتوسط
[موسيقى]
القيود غير المشروعه المفروضه على
الاقتصاد الروسي يمكن ان يكون لها بالفعل
تاثير سلبي على المدى المتوسط وفي هذا
الصدد نحتاج لضمان زياده مستدامه في الطلب
المحلي وفي هذه الحاله سيصبح هذا هو
العامل الرئيسي في نمو الاقتصادي في الوقت
الحالي ما زال قطاع التصنيع بطيئا لسوء
الحظ اقل من مستوى العام الماضي اطلب منكم
الانتباه الى هذا انه امر بالغ الاهميه
يبدو حديث بوتين عن التاثير على المدى
المتوسط او حتى البعيد منطقيا العرض
التالي يرصد لنا نظره اوسع على الاقتصاد
الروسي
الاقتصاد الروسي يتكبد عواقب الحرب
الاوكرانيه
تقلص الميزانيه العامه الروسيه انخفاض
معدلات الاستثمار الاجنبي
تراجع قيمه العمله بقرابه 20% زياده اسعار
النفط والغاز تقلص الايدي العامله
مؤشرات توحي بانهيار اقتصادي على المدى
البعيد
الملياردير الروسي اوليج قال انه لن تكون
هناك اموال في العام المقبل هو ان روسيا
بحاجه الى مستثمرين اجانب
فيما قال صندوق النقد الدولي ان خساره راس
المال البشري والعزل عن الاسواق الماليه
العالميه اضافه الى اعاقه الوصول الى
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه ستؤدي الى اعاقه
الاقتصاد الروسي
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل قطع للمياه وجفاف
غير مسبوق في تونس ومطالبات بحاله طوارئ
مائيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدر رئيس دوله الامارات
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قرارا بتعيين الشيخ
منصور بن زايد نائبا لرئيس الدوله الى
جانب الشيخ محمد بن راشد وقرر الشيخ محمد
بن زايد تعيين الشيخ خالد بن محمد بن زايد
وليا للعهد في اماره ابوظبي كما اصدر
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قرارا بتعيين الشيخ
هزاع بن زايد والشيخ طحنون بن زايد نائبين
لحاكمي ابوظبي
[موسيقى]
اعلنا مكتب الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق
هرتسوق ان المفاوضات بين احزاب الغالبيه
والمعارضه بشان خطه الاصلاح القضائي
المثيره للجدل استمرت الاربعاء بعد لقاء
اول جرى الثلاثاء انتهى بروح ايجابيه وفق
بيان المكتب وعقد اللقاء لقاء الحوار
الاول في مقر اقامه هرتسوك بين فرق العمل
التي تمثل الائتلاف الحاكم وحزبي المعارضه
عتيد وحزب الوحده الوطنيه كما ورد في
البيان
في الاثناء اعرب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو عن تفاؤله بانه سيجد حلا
وسطا مع المعارضه السياسيه بشان اصلاح
النظام القضائي في البلاد
[موسيقى]
كيف نضمن ان يظل القضاء مستقلا وان نوازن
بين الحاجه الى تعزيز السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه وفي نفس الوقت حمايه الحقوق
الفرديه اعتقد ان هذا التوازن يمكن تحقيقه
لهذا السبب روج لفتره وقفه تتيح للمعارضه
والائتلاف الجلوس ومحاوله تحقيق اجماع
وطني واسع لتحقيق كلا الهدفين واعتقد ان
هذا ممكن
ازمه اخرى يعانيها نتنياهو بسبب مشروع
التعديلات القضائيه ايضا لكن هذه المره مع
الرئيس الامريكي بايدن نتنياهو علق على
ذلك اليوم وقال ان واشنطن وتل ابيب بينهما
خلافات من ان لاخر لكن التحالف بينهما لا
يتزعزع
[موسيقى]
خلافات بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده من
حين لاخر لكن اريد ان اؤكد لكم ان التحالف
بين اعظم ديمقراطيه في العالم واسرائيل
الديمقراطيه قويه والفخوره المستقله هذا
التحالف لا يتزعزع ولا يمكن لشيء ان يغير
ذلك
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو صديقان
وحليفان وشريكاني في علاقه ممتده لما يقرب
من اربعه عقود كان بايدن سيناتورا صغيرا
في اوائل الاربعينات من عمره اما نتنياهو
الذي يصخره بعشر سنوات تقريبا كان
دبلوماسيا لا يزال يخطو خطواته الاولى
تطورت العلاقه على مدى السنين ليصبح
الثنائي صديقين عزيزين بدرجه انه في عام
2014 خرج بيضا ليقولا انه ابلغ نتنياهو
بالاتي لا اتفق مع اي شيء تقوله لكنني
احبك ربما الود لا يزال موجوده لكن غاب
الاتفاق
بالتلميح والتصريح ازمه التعديلات
القضائيه تخرج الى العالم الخلافات بين
الحليفين القويين من واشنطن الى تل ابيب
والعكس ايضا يرفض الرئيس الامريكي دعوه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى البيت الابيض
في المستقبل القريب فبايدن قلق للغايه يرى
ان الاستمرار في هذا الطريق ليس ممكنا في
اسرائيل
نتنياهو لا يتاخر يرد وبطريقه غير مسبوقه
رد حمل اشارات واضحه الى الولايات المتحده
اسرائيل لا تخضع لضغوط من الخارج بما في
ذلك من افضل الاصدقاء
وللاصدقاء تحديدا يقول وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي تمار بن غفير ان اسرائيل ليست
نجمه على العلم الامريكي متوقعا ان يفهم
بايدن هذه النقطه فهل فهمها بايدن القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه نقلت عن مسؤول
امريكي قوله ان نتنياهو اخطا فهم الرد
الامريكي على انقلابه القانوني المسؤول
الامريكي قال ايضا ان نتنياهو اساء
التقدير بتصريحاته حول بايدل خرجت
التصريحات اذا اصداؤها سمعت في اسرائيل
واشنطن لكنه صدن يعكس غضبا واحباطا
امريكيين من نتنياهو وحكومته كما تقول
صحيفه يدعو تحرنوت نقلا عن مسؤول اسرائيلي
كبير
الازمه الاخيره التي تابعنا التفاصيلها
جعلت نتنياهو بعد اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر من
توليه منصبه لا ينال دعوه حتى الان من
البيت الابيض وفقا لمراجعات رويترز
لزيارات الرسميه لرؤساء وزراء اسرائيل من
سبعينيات القرن الماضي وحتى الان زار معظم
الزعماء الاسرائيليين الجدد الولايات
المتحده او التقوا برئيسها في بدايه
رئاستهم للحكومه ما يشير الى استياء
واشنطن الواضح من سياسات حكومته اليمينيه
المستشار الامريكي الاسبق للمبعوث الخاص
للمفاوضات الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه
اكد ان الرساله من عدم الدعوه هي اذا
اتبعت السياسات اسرائيل اتبعت او هذه
الحكومه تحديدا اتبعت سياسات مرفوضه فانه
ليس من حقق يا نتنياهو الجلوس في المكتب
البيضاوي العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
تشهد اليوم اهتزازا في قاعدتها الصلبه
القيام المشتركه تضررت وتل ابيب تعمل خلا
المصالح الامريكيه الانيه بحسب ورقه عمل
مشتركه
للباحثين في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه اداتش
الورقه البحثيه دللت على الامر باستطلاع
جديد اجراه معهد غالوب للمره الاولى اكثر
من 49% من المستطلعين الامريكيين
المحسوبين على الحزب الديمقراطي يتماهون
مع الفلسطينيين اكثر من الاسرائيليين نسبه
تاييد الفلسطينيين ارتفعت السنه الاخيره
فقط بنسبه 11%
وتنضم الينا من واشنطن مديره مكتب العربيه
نادي البلبيسي ومن القدس مراسله العربيه
لا نقل غاسي اهلا بكنا معي يعني ابدا معك
ناديه كيف يمكن توصيف شكل العلاقه الان
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل
هل نتحدث عن فطور بالعلاقه واختلاف بالراي
عادي ام عن اهتزاز بالقيم قيم هذه العلاقه
نستطيع ان نقول راويه بانها علاقه متوتره
تمر بمرحله صعبه نوعا ما لكنها ليست
اهتزاز جذري او اساسي لانه العلاقه بين
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل مبنيه على
مصالح مشتركه وكانت عسكريه او امنيه الى
غيره لكن دوما كانت اسرائيل تتحدث عن
المفاهيم للديمقراطيه المشتركه مع هذا
تضعه نوعا ما لكن ما رايناه منذ بدايه
الازمه حتى الان هو محاوله احتواء من
البيت الابيض لعدم تدهور هذه العلاقه على
الاقل علنا يعني نعرف نحن بان الرئيس
بايدن اتصل مع نتنياهو وقال له وحثه بشكل
واضح وصريح بانه عليه عدم المضي قدوا قدما
في هذه الاجراءات القضائيه لكن قبل قليل
ان كنت في البيت الابيض وسالت جون كيربي
مناسب شؤون الاتصالات طبعا عن هل يشعر
الرئيس بايدن بالاهانه من تصريحات نت
وابنه نياهو وخصوصا وان العلاقه تاريخيه
بين اسرائيل او بين نتنياهو بالتحديد
والرؤساء الديمقراطيين سيئه يعني انا اذكر
ايضا كنت في داخل مكتب البيضاوي في عهد
الرئيس اوباما عندما كانت نتنياهو يعطي
محاضرات للرئيس اوباما وكانه تلميذ في
المدرسه وبالتالي هذا امر غير مقبول اكيد
بالنسبه للادارات الديمقراطيه لكن بايدن
بالتحديد يتمتع بعلاقه جيده جدا مع
اسرائيل اذا لم تكن ممتازه دوما هو كان
يقول لو لم تكن اسرائيل يجب ان نقلقها لكن
الان نتنياهو وضعه في على المحك ووضع هذه
العلاقه على المحل لدرجه ان بايدن قال
بشكل واضح بانني لن ادعو رئيس الوزراء ولا
اعرف متى سادعو رئيس الوزراء وهو اكثر
اكبر شريك استراتيجي للولايات المتحده
اكثر دوله محببه لواشنطن وهي اسرائيل نرى
غياب لهذه الدعوه من قبل ابقي معي ناديه
وايضا لانا سنستمع الان بما انه تحدثتي عن
هذا الخطاب
تصريح يعني التصريح لجونكر يعني حول هذا
الموضوع
اذا نظرنا الى تصريح نتنياهو هناك الكثير
من الايجابيات فيه تحدث عن البحث عن حل
الوسط وعن العمل على بناء توافق فيما
يتعلق بهذه الاصلاحات القضائيه المحتمله
وتحدث ايضا عن مدى ثباته في اهميه العلاقه
بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل وعن
احترامه الكبير للرئيس بايدن وهذا احترام
يشاركه فيه الرئيس بايدن ايضا نتنياهو
وبايدن يعرفان بعضهما منذ اربعين عاما
والشيء الرائع في الاصدقاء وانا متاكد من
ان لدينا اصدقاء جميعا فنحن لا نوافق
دائما على كل ما يفعله او يقوله اصدقائنا
والشيء الرائع في الصداقه العميقه هو اننا
يمكن ان نكون صريحين مع بعضنا
اعود اليك لانا كلاسي من القدس وايضا نادي
البلبيسي لنا تحديدا عن علانيه هذه
الخلافات ظهرت للعلن رغم طلب نتنياهو من
وزرائه عدم التصريح بشان العلاقه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نسمع وزير
التعليم الاسرائيلي مثلا يقول بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لن تملي على
اسرائيل
اداره شؤونها الداخليه والتصريحات اخرى
كيف ينظر باسرائيل الى هذه الخلافات وحتى
الان انه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبايرن لم يدعوا نتنياهو لزيارته
فعليا خطاب بايدن يثير غضب اليمين هنا في
اسرائيل نحن نتحدث عن ايضا غضب لوزراء
يمينيين وبالرغم من طلب
نتنياهو منهم من عدم التصريح وتعقيب على
ما قاله بايدن الا ان وزير الا ان الوزير
فعليا اعتبر بنجفير وهو وزير الماليه قد
قال وصرح
واكد بان فعليا اسرائيل هي ليست ولايه من
ولايات
الولايات المتحده اي يقول للولايات
المتحده لا تتدخل في شؤون اسرائيل وهذا
ايضا من شانه ان يزيد ايضا التوترات بين
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده ولكن ايضا
تصريح بايدن هو ايضا يدعم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه وهناك يعني المعارضه تشعر
بالرضا بشكل كبير من قبل تصريحات بايدن
وتقول وتدعم فعليا ان وقف التعديلات
القضائيه هو الامر الصحيح وهو ما يجب ان
يتم فعله لتبقى اسرائيل حسب وصفهم
بالديمقراطيه
ناديه ما راي الشارع الامريكي بشكل هذه
العلاقه لانه باستطلاع الراي الذي اوردناه
منذ قليل التاييد او التعاطف مع
الفلسطينيين زاد بالسنه الاخيره بشكل
ملحوظ
هذا صحيح وهي ظاهره في الحزب الديمقراطي
فقط يعني الشباب من الحزب وخصوصا ما يسمون
بالتقدميين او الجناح اليساري في بينهم
طبعا طلاب الجامعات هم الاكثر تعاطفا مع
الفلسطينيين ومع القضيه الفلسطينيه لكن
الجيل القديم بما فيه الرئيس بايدن لا
يزال يؤيد لاسرائيل يعني ظالمه او مظلومه
وبالتالي هذا الخلاف لانه هو علني اصبح
الان ربما نقطه سجليه لكن حتى بين اعضاء
الكونجرس ومراكز الفكر المعروفه بما تدعم
اسرائيل هناك اختلاف مع حكومه نتنياهو
لنذكر مره اخرى بانه هذه الحكومه هي
الاكثر تطرف في تاريخ اسرائيل وهي حكومه
يمينيه وبالتالي عندما يكون هناك مثلا
رئيس وزراء من حزب العمل او من احزاب اخرى
ليست من ضمن تحالف الليكود سيكون هناك
انسجام اكثر مع الح الديمقراطيه والعكس
صحيح راينا ذلك بين نتنياهو وبين الرئيس
ترامب لكن بشكل عام الراي العام الامريكي
بمجمله حسب السن طبعا ينقسم مؤيد لاسرائيل
وخصوصا الانجيليين المسيحيين الشباب
الصغار بالعمر وخصوصا المتعلمين وطلبه
الجامعه مؤيدين الفلسطينيين وهذا سيؤثر
على المدى البعيد ربما سنحتاج الى جيل من
الامريكيين لتتغير وجهه النظر بشكل كبير
لصالح الفلسطينيين لكن هذا سياخذ وقت طويل
واموال كثيره يعني تنفق على المرشحين قبل
ان يصلوا الى الكونجرس وكانوا في مجلسين
هل هو الشيوخ شكرا جزيلا لك ناديه
البلبيسي وايضا لا نقل غاصيه
[موسيقى]
حاله ترقب في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في ظل التقارير التي تفيد بقرب التوجيه
لائحه اتهام ضد الرئيس الجمهوري السابق
دون ترامب بتهام مرتبطه بدفع مبالغ ماليه
لاحدى الممثلات وقالت مصادر لشبكه سي ان
ان مكتب المدعي العام في منهات بنيويورك
لم يتخذ اي اجراء حتى الان ضد ترامب بتهم
مرتبطه بدفع مبالغ ماليه واضافت المصادر
انه من غير المتوقع ان تنظر هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى في قضيه ترامب مره اخرى هذا
الاسبوع فيما قالت رويترز ان الهيئه لن
تجتمع قبل اجازات عيد الفصح وكان موقع
ذهيل اشار الى انه توجيه لائحه اتهام ضد
ترامب امر غير مؤكد وفي حال اذا حدث
ستتركز الاتهامات على التزوير تزوير
السجلات او خرق قوانين تمويل الانتخابات
او كليهما
في الاثناء وصف محامي دونالد ترامب او
محاميه جو تاكوبينا منشورات الرئيس السابق
ضد مدعي عام منطقه منهاتن الذي يحقق معه
في جرائم ماليه محتمله وصفها بغير الحكيم
المزيد في التالي
[موسيقى]
انا لست مستشارا في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بهذه الجمله اخلى محامي الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب مسؤوليته عن
اي منشورات لترامب فهل تخلى اقرب موظفي
الرئيس الامريكي عنه
يعرف عن ترامب حبه وعشقه لمواقع التواصل
التي لطالما استخدمها لايصال رسائله
الخاصه لخصومه اخرها وجهت لشخص لم يكن
خصما ولا منافسا هو مدعي عاما هاتا الفن
براج المسؤول عن التحقيق في قضايا جنائيه
ماليه تلاحق ترامب اثناء حملته الانتخابيه
عام 2016 قبل ايام صعد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق من لهجته واشار في منشور الله عبر
منصته للتواصل
الى موت ودمار محتملين اذا تم توجيه
الاتهام اليه في القضيه
سبقتها جمله من ردات الفعل للرئيس
الامريكي السابق عبر سلسله تغريدات له
اثار بعضها حفيظه مناصريه ودفعت اخرين
للتحذير من تداعياتها تحدث فيها ترامب عن
مزاعم اعتقاله
هنا نعود للسؤال عن تفسير تصريحات ابرز
شخص حاليا في قضيه ترامب الجنائيه محاميه
والمدافع عنه جو تاكوبينا انتقد منشورات
الرئيس الامريكي السابق على الانترنت ضد
مدعي منطقه من هاته ووصفها بغير الحكيمه
لكنه في الوقت نفسه لم يتخلى عن موكله
تماما بل اشار الى ان ترامب لم ينشر تلك
التهديدات بنفسه
اعتقد ان هذا كان منشورا غير حكيم وضعه
احد العاملين على وسائل التواصل وسرعان ما
حذفه عندما ادرك الخطاب والصوره المرفقه
به صرح ترامب ام لم يصرح ودين ام لم يدن
اذا كان هناك شيء واحد اصبح واضحا بشكل
متزايد بشان مستقبل ترامب الرئاسي لعام
2024 فهو ان هذه الحمله ستكون اكثر شراسه
من سابقتها
روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
موجه جفاف غير مسبوقه تعيشها تونس امر جعل
الحكومه تقطع ليلا مياه الشرب لتخرج اصوات
تنادي بضروره اعلان حاله الطوارئ المائيه
نقص المياه في تونس يثير قلق الاهالي
وينظر بازمه جديده في البلاد تضاف الى
اخرى بينها ماليه واقتصاديه الحكومه وان
كانت لم تقر بازمه المياه بشكل مباشر
لكنها اخذت احتياطاتها مثل قطع المياه
ليلا في مناطق بينما تعاني اخرى اضطرابات
في توزيع المياه خلال النهار مشكله اكثر
حاجه تعقد المواطن نحن محتاجين للماء برشا
بوسي لكل شيء عندي فيهم باش نغسله واحد
حتى باش يتوضا يصلي ولا مايقاش حتى مثقفون
واكاديميون القوا باللومي على الحكومه
بسبب عدم استعدادها لمواجهه شح المياه رغم
التحذيرات لم نقم بمر لسياساتنا العموميه
في مجال المياه على مستوى الاستهلاك
المنزلي على مستوى الاستهلاك الفلاحي وعلى
ما المستوى الاستهلاك الصناعي وغيرها مدن
تونسيه عديده تعالت فيها الاصوات ضد
انقطاع المياه وتاثيره على حياتهم اليوميه
خاصه خلال شهر رمضان
انقطاعات غير معلنه وليليه تقريبا في
العديد من الجهات وخاصه مدن الكبرى كما
تونس الكبرى الوطن القبلي مدن الساحل
وتقريب ولايه صفاقس وهي المناطق التي تعد
حوالي سته مليون ساكن وامام تفاقم الازمه
تقول الحكومه ان نقص المياه ياتي بسبب
تراجع مخزون السدود وشح الامطار فيما يحذر
خبراء البيئه من ازمه مياه صعبه وعطش ربما
يهدد التونسيين عند بدايه الصيف جاسم محسن
العربيه
واقعه بين قوتين عضميين خارجيا وقوتين
اخريين داخليا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم عمالقه التكنولوجيا عالقون بين
واشنطن وبيكين في صراعهما بالامس ادلى
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك توك بشهاده
امام الكونغرس واليوم المدير التنفيذي
لابل في الصين حيث طلبته بتقويه اجراءات
حمايه البيانات
هنا في الكونجرس يدلي المدير التنفيذي
لتيك توك شيزو بشهادته في حين ان المدير
التنفيذيه لشركه ابل تمكوك موجود في بكين
والقى خطابا امام منتدى التنميه الصيني
السنوي والمطالب من الطرفين الثابته حمايه
البيانات عملا بمبدا المعامله بالمثل طلبت
الصين تيم كوك بتقويه ابل لاجراءات حمايه
البيانات لكن عكس التيك توك في امريكا
فالصين هي شريك رئيسي وسوق كبير للشركه
ابل تقول ان مبيعاتها في الربع الاخير من
العام الماضي قدرت باربعه وعشرين مليار
دولار تقريبا في الصين ما يجعل البلاد
ثاني اكبر سوق لمبيعات ابل خارج الولايات
المتحده بعد اوروبا
امر اخر مختلف فيما يخص التطبيقات
والاجهزه الالكترونيه في الصين والولايات
المتحده افضل تطبيقات الصينيه وجدت جمهورا
كبيرا في الولايات المتحده
150 مليون مستخدم النشط شهريا لتيك توك
مثلا لكن القليل من التطبيقات الامريكيه
قادره على اختراق السوق الصينيه حيث ان
معظم عمالقه البرمجيات في الولايات
المتحده غير قادرين على العمل في الصين
بسبب مطالب الرقابه لكن ابل تحاول تغيير
هذه الصوره حيث سجلت ارقام شحنها للهواتف
خلال الربع الثاني من العام الماضي
ارتفاعا قياسيا بتسعه ملايين وتسعمائه الف
جهاز بالمقارنه مع نفس الفتره من عام 2021
[موسيقى]
تجد نفسها واقعه بين القوتين العظميين
الصين والولايات المتحده ومسؤولون حاليون
وسابقون يتجهون الى الدولتين الرئيسه
الحاليه لتايوان
ستقوم بزياره الى حليفتي تايوان غوتيمالا
ذها
من المتوقع ان تلتقي رئيسه تايوان برئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي من مكارتي في لوس
انجلوس في الخامس من الشهر المقبل فيما
يبدو لقاء مصمما لتجنب الاحداث التي تلت
زياره نانسي بلوسي العام الماضي الى
تايوان التي رفضت التعامل مع التساي منذ
انتخابها عام 2016 رفعت شكوى للولايات
المتحده بشان الزياره واتهمت الرئيسه
بالترويجي لاستقلال تايوان
اذا اتصلت برئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
مكارثي سيكون هذا استفزازا اخر ينتهك بشكل
خطير مبدا الصين الواحده ويؤذي سياده
الصين وسلامتها الاقليميه ويدمر السلامه
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان نحن نعارض ذلك
بشده وسنتخذ بالتاكيد اجراءات للرد بحزم
من جانبها قالت ان تايوان دوله ذات سياده
بالفعل ولا حاجه لاعلان الاستقلال تايوان
ستشهد انتخابات رئاسيه في يناير القادم
وفي خضم الاستعدادات لها زرع الرئيس
السابق ما
الصين موجها رساله للتقارب بينما اسماهم
الصينيين على جانبي مضيق تايوان ما بات
اول مسؤول تايواني رفيعي يزور الصين
لزياره ضريح سانيات سن الذي ينظر عليه على
انه الاب الروحي لتايوان واطلق عليه بعد
وفاته لقب ابو الامه
[موسيقى]
اوضحت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين ان تطبيق تنقل
هو احد تطبيقات الرئاسه العامه او تطبيق
تنقل هو احد تطبيقات الرئاسه العامه لشؤون
المسجد الحرام والمسجد النبوي يهدف
التطبيق لتقديم خدمه لضيوف الرحمن للقيام
بحج العربات الكهربائيه للطواف والسعي
داخل المسجد الحرام ويسهل هذا التطبيق
عمليه شراء التذاكر والحجز المسبق لتقليل
التزاحم على نقاط بيع التذاكر وتسليم
العربات مما يحقق التباعد الامن بين
المعتمرين
ومعنا من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلم مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك معنا السلطان يعني طبعا
بظل الاعداد الكبيره
للمعتمرين العربات الكهربائيه هي الحل
لتسهيل تنقلهم اخبرنا اكثر عن حجم
الاستفاده منها خاصه لذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه
للكبار في السن كيف يعني راينا انو تحجز
عبر التطبيق ولكن مواقعها اين تكون
بالفعل يعني منذ بدايه شهر رمضان وحتى
اليوم اكثر من 80 الف مستفيد من العربات
الكهربائيه واكثر من 95 الف مستفيد من
العربات المتحركه يتم توزيع هذه العربات
في الميزانين في الدور الارضي عفوا في
الدور الاول والدور الثاني وكذلك في الصفا
والمرورما ويستطيع والمروه عفوا ويستطيع
الطائف استخدام هذه العربات واداء نسك
العمره بكل يسر وسهوله نتحدث انه اعداد
كبيره يشهدها الحرم المكي ونتحدث تحديدا
كما يظهر امامكم صحن المطاف وهو ممتلئ
بالكامل لذلك يلجا المعتمرون للادوار
العلويه للاستفاده من هذه العربات التي
يستطيع المعتمر ان يقوم باستئجارها عبر
تطبيق التنقل التي خصصه التي خصصه رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين ليستطيع من خلالها المعتمر
حجز موعد واستلام عربته بشكل الكتروني
ويستطيع من خلالها الطواف والسعي في مده
لا تتجاوز الساعه والعشر دقائق يستطيع من
خلال هذه العربات يعني قطع الاشواط السبعه
للطواف والصفا والمروه في ساعه في مده
تتجاوز الساعه تحديدا يعني هذه العربات
متطوره وهي اعرابات سريعه لها مخصصه ولها
مشرفين يعملون على
يبدو ان صوتك يعني يقوموا بمساعده كبار
السن تفضل تفضل سلطان هل الصوت واضح نعم
نعم واضح الان بالفعل كنت تتحدث ان هنالك
نعم كنت تتحدث هنالك مسارات خاصه لهذه
العربات في الادوار العلويه للحرم المكي
وهنالك مرشدين ومرشدات يقومون بمساعده
كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه في خلال
تعليمهم قياده هذه هذه العربات وكذلك
الركوب معهم في هذه العربه التي تستطيع
استحمال شخصين وهنالك عربات اخرى مخصصه
لشخص واحد ومن ثم يقومون بتطويفهم وكذلك
في العمليات السعي ايضا نتحدث انه
الاسعار التي يستطيع من خلالها تاجيرها او
استاجارها المعتمر لا تتجاوز 120 ريال
لعمليه اداء نسك العمره بالكامل هذه
الاعرابات سهلت كثيرا على كبار السن وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه لاداء النسك بكل يسر
وسهوله ايضا نتحدث انه يستطيع المعتمر
صوره اليوم مشاهدينا من باكستان النساء
كلهن يمدن ايديهن ببطاقات الهويه سعيا
للحصول على الطحينه الذي اعلن رئيس
الوزراء شهباز شريف توفيره بشكل مجاني
خلال شهر رمضان الحصول على الطحين حتى وان
كان مجانيا يتطلب تحمل هذا الازدحام بينما
هناك مهمه اخرى مهمه النقل هذه السيده
الباكستانيه حملت كل هذه الكيلوغرامات فوق
راسها حتى الوصول لبيتها
اما تصريح اليوم فهو للرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب خلال مقابله مع فاكس
نيوز قال لو لم ادعمه لكان مصير ديسانتس
العمل في محل بيتزا هكذا تحدث ترامب عن
منافسه على نيل ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
للانتخابات الرئاسه 2024 ترامب يقصد هنا
الدعم الذي قدمه ليديسانس خلال الانتخابات
التمهيديه عام 2018
لمنصب حاكم فلوريدا الرئيس السابق وصف
دعمه للرجل بانه كان بمثابه سلاح نووي رجح
الكفه لديسانس لكن هل كان السلاح النووي
او هذا البات الان موجها في وجه ترامب
الاجابه خلال الشهر
فيديو اليوم هو من عمان لفريق اردني مكون
من مصابين بمتلازمه داون يرقصون رقصه
الدبكه الشهيره انشا الفريق مجموعه من
الامهات قبل ثلاث سنوات لمنحي ابنائهن
فرصه للالتقاء والتدريب والاداء في
الاماكن العامه في محاوله لتحسين ثقتهم
بانفسهم ومواجهه التنمر الذي يتعرضون اليه
بالفعل تغيرت نفسيه الشباب حياتهم بالكامل
تغيرت الام هي المشجع والداعم الاساسي في
كل الاوقات وفي كل ظروف والعجب ان الجنه
تحت اقدامها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله يخلي كل الامهات والان الى صهيب
شراير واخبار الساعه ويخلي لك امك وحماتك
شكرا يا راويه اكيد طبعا وكما ذكرتي الجنه
تحت اقدام الامهات ويخلي لك الست الوالده
كذلك تحيه لكل الامهات في هذا المساء اذا
اخبار الساعه ايضا بعد قليل كالعاده جوله
سريعه شامله ومتنوعه من اخبار اليوم في
الصداره امريكا تدعو تدخل على خط
التعديلات القضائيه في اسرائيل بايدن يضغط
على نتنياهو شكرا تفضل شكرا لك شكرا
[موسيقى]